I mentioned the idea of doing
mathematical morphology.
That is, fixing up your picture.
Okay?
And, fundamentally,
there are two basic operations, and
they're referred to as dilation and
erosion.
We're going to go through
both of those in detail.
Once you have those
two basic operations,
you can combine those to
make more operations.
Eh, there are a whole bunch of them, and
this used to be a whole industry
doing mathematical morphology.
The ones that we use most to date,
or I should say,
the ones that we use most currently, are
various forms of closing and opening,
and we're going to talk about those.
Then there's thinning and
thickening, and a few other things,
but they all stem from these two basic
operations of dilation and erosion.
So let's go through those.
So dilation is exactly what
it sounds like, right,
when you dilate something it expands.
And so dilation, expands the connected
set of ones in the binary image.
So, here you see this thing expand,
if you get bigger, and really,
you know, just grew out, and
were going to talk about the mechanisms
by which you do dilation, and
something called the structuring
elements which control the shape.
This one is an interesting one, right?
Everything expanded and
has two effects, first of all,
things got a little straighter.
But also, notice that these
little cutouts went away.
Likewise, when this thing got bigger,
okay, the holes went away.
Dilation in general can be used for,
like it says, filling holes and gaps.
The, inverse, converse, reverse?
The other,
of dilation is called erosion, okay?
Erosion, just like when beaches and
other things erode,
is you're essentially
shrinking the shape.
Right?
So this big bar becomes a narrower bar,
this big circle becomes
a smaller circle.
Here's where you start to see its power,
right?
These two connected, sort of
elliptical things become, like here,
it's this case, it's these two circular
things, you, you, could actually do it,
go from those ellipses and circles.
The important thing is that
middle part went away.
And here you see that these little
protuberances went away when the entire
thing shrank, and
that's referred to as erosion, okay.